oh God hi welcome back to bendy and the
dark Revival I didn't need to be that
close to that person but I got the
Whomping stick wait a minute I got the
one pink stick I thought that out I
thought they already had the Whomping
stick can I just stop at the one I
probably just stopped the Whomping stick
no I didn't stop at the one I already
had the Whomping stick however now I
want you
I remember you took more woman than that
I thought I saved but apparently I
didn't but anyway welcome back I'm not
too far off from where I was oh tokens I
can use that on the vending machine that
I saw elsewhere oh
hello
and now I can womp things it probably
doesn't want me to want things as many
times as I want to want things but you
know that's not really the game's choice
at this point it gave me the lump and
stick so I'm going to use it to Womp
well let's see Jen cards still required
there oh yeah yeah oh God hi that's a
lot of you to want
hey hey
can I get like a Charged attack I want
dark tide mechanics here
well they didn't have anything worth
looting so I didn't actually do anything
yeah
hello food
anything in there cool
no we hit rock bottom no doubt about it
and by all accounts I don't even know
how this Studio's still going at all
like if you follow the money you just
hit a big old brick wall well let me
tell you blank ledgers spare cash you
know weird amounts the plane just don't
add up there's still income finding its
way under the books but I can only tell
you for the life of me I can't figure
out where it's all coming from though
the obvious answer here is a Jin's
privately pouring in some funds then
truth be told they really freaked me out
especially that Mr Gray uh he doesn't
seem to be motivated by money many sure
as heck ain't telling us what he's
really after
just can't trust someone like that just
can't trust someone like that definitely
not but also I don't even know who this
is so what do I know I heard some of the
workers from down the hall last night
talking about storming Joey true's
office they were using some colorful
language banging their fists on the
tables and chairs it was the same Bunch
who whistled at me yesterday things must
be getting serious that account in Grant
Cohen just walks up from his desk down
to the men's room and go back all day
over and over again gripping his stomach
kind of green in the gills I can't tell
if something he ate isn't agreeing with
a Murphy just can't take the pressure
anymore he's always got a plan he keeps
saying gent is making something special
I really hope he's right I may just be a
secretary but this place has a magic I
don't want to see end oh it's kind of
magic all right he's got a magic that
everyone's gonna be a part of whether
they like it or not hi that Wilson he's
everywhere yet he's nowhere I don't know
how he does it it's madness madness what
if he's inside my mind what if he hears
my thoughts can you hear me now Wilson
can you penis butts [ __ ] you won't
get me I've got a plan if I tear out my
brain then you can't hear my mind yeah
I'll show you you I defy you all hail
the ain't demon hell he's not dead I
tell you he will rise again and his dark
Revenge will be terrible well that was a
perfectly sane letter and I'm glad that
I read it exactly as it was written full
intention to the exact intonations of
every syllable
anyway
s Sure I'll take a battery sure
well I'm back here but I don't know why
ooh vending machines may have some food
buy times five
times five of what
that took five coins to get one bag of
chips when they got a bajillion bags of
Chip lying around everywhere well I
don't know why I did that I don't know
if there was anything else to lump here
down
I doubt the wall is gonna cave in
uh that's locked fully charged gent
charged
I don't know what you mean by charged
but maybe I need to go to the workbench
anybody else want to be wumped
how was oh
I mean that didn't answer my question
hey hey stop stop stop stop stop stop
stop stop stop stop stop stop you're not
stopping you should be stopping at this
point
he's playing a mouth heart while I'm
getting the crap beat out of me it is
surprisingly menacing so it did work
but at the same time I'm kind of
confused hello
okay
so for that particular thing it might be
better just to run away like a little
baby which I'm not but I'll act like it
if it gets me away from harm oh
I see now
I see
I don't know if it's like a good thing
to just start whapping and pulling every
single lever that I see one of them is
going to be an airlock that's going to
send me out into ink space or something
like that
oh this is safe
Hey look it's safe just like I was
saying
what
oh hi hey oh God
as I suspected it was all a figment of
my imagination and was never actually a
harm to me at all can I not eat any of
those cans I don't assume that there's
actually food in them ever I'm assuming
I'm just crunching on the aluminum
exterior or tin I guess at this point in
the world if this is the world which
probably is not okay anyway though that
was fun
oh
hi oh
can you not goop all over the windows be
very much you don't have to kill me I
don't have to
do I not have to
the boss seems like I have to my
murderous left hand really wants to
uh-huh well here comes the death oh
I look so cool the powers of the ink are
yours to command that's
awesome use your powers to send monsters
back to the dark puddles while crouched
in undetected interact with an enemy
from behind to banish them Vanishing
also restores a Porsche I eat them
almost
eat you I'm not kidding get it
it's so eating you
I consider it Canon that I just consumed
your essence your Inky Essence I slurped
it straight from the source right out of
the tap I did
take one again
well hell yeah that was amazing
didn't really seem to absorb a lot of
Health points or replenish it from when
I
slurped up the ink demon but at the same
time why does that happen ing
ink
I am uncertain
I am hesitant jump
oh have more faith in yourself your legs
are strong I won't go that way who's
groaning
who's moaning
what pause it
oh
oh
what is what is what is what's this
what's this what is this stupid thing I
just put a battery in it I better
actually tell me what it is
exchange Card Exchange what is this
create one gen card
okay
I did it uh how do I not have enough
parts to do that again
okay what what did you do what did you
do
but what does it do
oh hey whoa hey
where do I go is there a hiding hole
am I not coming after me did you guys
like my very real screams
of Terror and or delight and I guess
this is as good as time as any to
confess that all of my screams up until
this point in my entire YouTube career
have been fake
okay safe and sound just sounds like
it's a hiding place is that really what
I want
why does it sound so goopy well I'm not
gonna know until I thought
all right not not too bad it's safe
unsurprisingly it's a it's a safe did
that give more materials than it took to
actually make the thing because I don't
even think I have enough to make another
one because I'm missing that one
well that was fun I guess but it didn't
do me any good so oh that one I could
hide in all right whatever I'll move the
damn thing now
[Music]
maybe I can make that jump if I can't
push that very fast
my bones too weak all Ink No calcium
ah that looks important
ah I get to consume you
from the outside in as things usually
are consumed I don't know if anyone in
existence says consumed something from
the inside out
but what do I know
[Music]
what
I want to die
I don't know what that what did you say
don't cry for me I don't want to die I
sure wish there were subtitles I swear I
turned on subtitles subtitles they
should be on but they're not on uh maybe
they just didn't subtitle everything
are you coming over here or what
oh you is well you're gonna be consumed
oh
I'm adaming you oh you had a friend oh I
see ah wait okay
all right
well no not here
no
no
I am one hit away I'm one hit I'm one
hit I'm one shot I'm one shot
didn't Crouch
he didn't Crouch
he didn't Crouch why am I back here oh
I swear you slurping
that's what I thought
do I still have the powers
do I still have the powers that be
should have been my
Sprint made another one of those things
but it's fine
[Music]
slurp this is what you get yes
thank you it sure seems lethal but what
do I know well anyway I sure went out of
my way for that see if I can what
what
well I won't ask well I'm looking this
way now apparently well I won't ask too
many questions I'll just make another
one of these because I think I got what
I needed to do that yeah just always low
on those huh hey why is it did have it
did it get reset or not did it did it
did it did it did
not push oh God
wait it's not pushing
oh no no no no no no no no no no no no
no
I'm broken I'm broken again God how do I
keep doing this how do I keep doing this
how do I keep oh how do I keep doing
this
ah all right it's fine you know why it's
fine because I say it's fine no matter
what I have the saves that I can go back
and do what I need to do ah good okay
that's good we like that we like that so
so much
whoa you guys are being a little Twitchy
I don't like that
but I like the other thing that I was
saying I like so much you coming all the
way over here you're gonna come all the
way over here I don't really have a
hidey hole oh God this is not the best
place to be
what did you just do
you still okay
dinner
so slow when I'm crawling I'm so slow
there we go everything is as it should
be
all right now for the next one
hello
yeah what happened to your friend oh
don't round this corner and look
straight at me no don't do that [ __ ]
fool fool can I not why am I not
I eat you so hard
I literally could not have Eed you any
harder it's not like you actually saw me
I was behind you maybe I was full maybe
that's what it was maybe I was full
anyway I'm here now hi what's going on
can I get a studio tour here's where the
magic
his man I'm Joey true and our Story
begins quite literally in one of our
many writers just like this one that's
right all your favorite bendy cartoons
are born right here we Circle up our
chairs crack open a cold drink and toss
around dozens of story possibilities
there's no bad ideas here we've all got
something we can bring to the scripts I
myself have been known to spend a lot of
time down here with the fellas tossing
in my own brand of Joey Drew Magic it's
my job to push the envelope with my big
s and I love it yes sir you'll always
hear endless laughter coming from the
writer's room
the script Finds Its way to our many
artists in the art Department you'll be
seeing our real Joey true Studios team
hard at work on our tour of Animation
Ally very shortly but right here you can
see a typical office where characters
are being lovingly crafted with very
careful attention to details I like to
stand over their shoulders as the
artists work
it's my job to catch the little things
that make our cartoons really extra
special if I see one of Betty's gloves
is missing his signature two dots I make
sure I tell someone that showing true
they like to say what a canine over time
the cartoon is slowly created frame by
frame Benny begins to walk and dance
it's really quite fantastic before long
we have our finished cartoon all ready
for the boys in the sound Department to
take over
okay good great that's really good I
don't like the mannequins I I really
don't
[Music]
disagree once a cartoon's animation is
finished it's ready for all the sound to
be added from music and voices to
outrageous sound effects they do it all
it's no wonder people say Joey Drew
Studios has the most impressive talent
in the world
you'll get a glimpse of my songwriting
tour Sammy Lawrence and Jack fayne
working on a new catchy tune with our
very own Studio Orchestra or radial spot
Mrs Allison Bethel Street recording the
voice of our favorite sent from above
Alice angel on the Joey Drew Studios
tour here in animation alley you never
know what will happen so keep your eyes
and ears open
but before we head into the main Studio
to see the actual magic makers at work
let's
stop into our award-winning editing room
this is where they put all the
ingredients together to create the final
cartoons that you'll see in
theater the editing room
is spots in the holes
[Music]
lots of work
okay I'm gonna I'm gonna just go I'm
gonna just go battery refill I don't
even know what that means what do I
have one of our editors Carl always has
lots to do but he always gets it done on
time hang in there Carl what a trooper
and now it's time to move into animation
alley and see the Joey Drew Studios
family at work take small children by
the hand as we enter the nerve center
of the company get ready for a big bendy
Adventure
what do I do how do I get through common
oh man ah so excited
oh I see I should have done this ages
ago I can't wait to get a behind the
scenes look at all the amazing work that
everyone's definitely not over
encumbered with
definitely not we're in the final days
here I can tell people are packing
things into boxes tools are going
missing you can smell the panic in the
air around the studio but us gen boys
we're just watching from the Shadows we
lock the doors and keep our research
going Mr Gray already gave us a little
wink all is well when one ships thinks
another one leaves the dock I just need
to keep my ink machine safe in the chaos
it's the key to so many discoveries
Thomas Connor I don't remember any of
these names so I I would never know if
there was actually someone that has been
mentioned before it's it's not the
game's fault it's my own lack of
attention span probably hi is there
mannequin's gonna be in the next area
sir is there happy mannequins in the
next area take that
and oh yeah I must have warmed you
before I'm going to assume
oh
I feel like this should have bad
I feel like this is bad
[Music]
I feel like it might be bad
I feel like it might be bad I got a bad
feeling I got one of those bad feelings
here to do a glove inspection you got
those signature two dots I was forced to
look at the four for some reason hey
nice trash can hmm you're not taking
care of these pots let me turn my back
on you for a bit
all right let's have let's have a
conversation here you and I
[Music]
so amazing it's okay
it's okay
it's okay come closer
yes weird handshake oh I heard you
[Music]
know
sorry well you know I could have only
assumed
[Music]
delicious ink was that Luigi this is so
so hungry bad day it's okay you can
trust me come closer don't grab that
hand that's the dangerous hand bendy
unless you come back
why don't you come back hi Wham
don't knock I'm knocking I'm not gonna
go
who's out there is that you Phil
I told you I'm not opening the door
until you bring me my pictures I drew
them I want them back well why don't you
take my hand then
why do I care about this I have no idea
why I care I had nothing to say on the
matter what does it say the dark puddles
are calling that's great for them
um
but I don't care
oh
another one of these non-door doors
good thing I've seen that before
uh
[Music]
I don't think I can show that on YouTube
and you
how's it to you
the power belongs to him who him who oh
it's the other side is it the other side
no it's not the other side this is not
the same place where there just happened
to be a gap here as well
uh-huh
okay uh but what would even be the oh
I can fall
yeah damn it
uh
uh good thing there are no consequences
for that ever I'm gonna make that jump I
can make it I didn't think I could do it
before but I know this one I can do it
I'm gonna make it I'm gonna make it here
oh I hit my head on a pipe you kidding
me all right take two three the next
take that I'm doing did I hit my head on
my pipe I think I did hit my head on him
something
oh it was an invisible wall I could
totally make that jump it just doesn't
want me to fine I'll go around with the
stupid way around you stupid in the
stupid but everyone knows that I could
have made that all of you know every of
you know
foreign
man I'm kind of slow
hope something spooky doesn't happen
hello his eyes see all his claws tear
and thrash his Whispers turn your mind
into dark unspeakable trash listen for
the heartbeat drone your doom is close
at hand the ink demon is both beast and
Lord his powers to have asked for us to
understand death is fast death is near
his reign will last beyond your fear uh
all right should I be aware of that
right now
is right now when I need to start
worrying about that
I'm surely not in this dark cramped vent
where something could be right behind me
that would be something to worry about
like that that you just described
certainly not
thank you
uh well okay
I'm so wicked
foreign
well
I was worried but I didn't hear a
heartbeat that's what the message told
me to listen for and I didn't hear it so
I'm guessing all is well okay
if only I hadn't
[Music]
used
well that's wonderful for the ink
I think you've smoked too much ink demon
I don't know why uh
you're so ominous but again much like
Wilson a little more uh
subtlety would be appreciated hello is
that you
are
if you would live
if you would let me finish my name is
Markiplier
so sweet so delicious whatever
oh yeah
I didn't expect that
it's adorable do I not have a head I oh
I I did not have that for a moment
interesting that's I I'm curious about
the tech behind that reasoning my arm
just disappeared
but I don't know
all right
probably nothing
probably
oh I didn't mean to
I also do that when I pick up
memories is it was the memory something
that I actually needed to look at I
can't even remember unlocked upgrades I
don't have any vanish okay
memories a rubber duck still dusted with
the decay of old soap many happy
Washings were companioned by this yellow
friend you tell me this thing is still
soaked with the stagnant bath water of
Untold numbers numbers of people
and I just pocketed that
yo
hey what's up
hey how you doing
my name is Markiplier
good thing you're slow
watch out I'll devour you
[Music]
oh the ink demon is near his powers
infinite his evil is complete be alert
for his approach and hide it first
warning if you stay on the open you'll
be consumed or I'll consume it
I might oh right now right now oh you
mean right now you oh you mean right now
oh collected a picture okay you mean
like right now oh
oh [ __ ] gross what do you means
I don't have a high deal
[Music]
I kind of picked up on that
I kind of picked up on that
um
uh-huh
okay are you actually here or
that sounds like a heartbeat that sounds
like a hearty beat
oh I think that might be heartbeat don't
hear me
oh
okay
I'm unsure
oh
that sounds like a heartbeat and that
sounds like the thing that I was warned
about
it's like full-on alien isolation here
well I don't like this I don't like any
of this
I don't like this at all
hello
also shut up and go away
and be I'll be your friend
oh God
okay
oh God
where are you
this is very ominous and spooky I don't
even know where it is
I have no idea what's happening
[Music]
[Applause]
I have a clock
a dancing time
[Laughter]
my movements
I have so many characters to animate yet
foreign
[Laughter]
man good stuff I don't know if that
heartbeat is just in the Ambiance or if
there's actually something to worry
about I don't know it seems like it
might actually be something to worry
about and I don't want to run the risk
that it's not something to worry about
that I just don't worry about it because
that's how I end up dead
lot of the time
usually I end up dead by either taunting
the enemies
or
getting overconfident
I might give you a lot of batteries I
just don't know what they're for
what are you are you dead you better be
dead you better be dead you better be
okay that's a hidey hole okay good good
hello picture that's that's scary
uh give me your essence no
it is something it's definitely
something because it went away too quick
want to wait too quick for it is just
beyond beyond
am I crazy am I crazy I might be crazy
don't tell me if I'm crazy
why does that sound like there's
something itching in my brain it's like
amnesia the Dark Descent and the
Cockroaches are in your ear
oh another hidey hole they wouldn't give
me this many hidey holes if he wasn't
around
if we if he wasn't like for reals he's
around
crazy
maybe maybe I'm crazy I haven't even
heard like footsteps or anything like
that
oh
wait what do you mean what was I done
well I wasn't done what are you I wasn't
I wasn't done
well you didn't what what huh you didn't
let me get every what oh good yeah
foreign
okay so
at least I get an alert but also why did
why do you what what
are you doing you don't why can't
that doesn't make any sense
why is it like this why is it like that
why is it like that I don't know
I don't know
I don't know what that's about
it's very strange but I'm not going to
worry about it
clearly not giving me what I need might
be a bug might not be a bug maybe it's
just
okay
I don't recall it being that time
sensitive before did I not pick up the
coins over there also I don't know how
many pictures I need for this guy and I
don't know why I'm getting the pictures
I could have just drained his Essence
straight out of his ass
but I didn't
hey
hey
what are you doing
what are you doing
okay a lot of nothing that's what you're
doing
a whole lot of nothing
well I'm up here now there's no way you
could get me I gotta figure out which
way I'm supposed to go because that's
just back down well this doesn't seem
too helpful because that's just the way
that I could have gone anyway so
whatever
a lot of hoopla that's what it is a lot
of hoopla
a lot of hoopla
I don't know why you got so many of
those what is this supposed to be some
animation artifact
I don't like it nope don't like it
I knew it I knew it I knew it I knew it
I knew it oh
well easy enough okay well if it's
scripted then I'm not gonna be nearly as
worried as I was before that should be
totally fine
okay you had me panicked there for a
little bit you had to be Panic thinking
that it could pop out at any moment
little did I know
it was simply a ruse
they're cruel prank
okay how do I get up there there was oh
another one right here
this place is beautiful in a way
I don't know if people were here when
everything was turning into animation
colors and shapes and whatnot everything
was being consumed by the ink maybe they
didn't even notice
but you know it's kind of nice the
illusion of living hey I remember that
book
oh nothing surely bad will happen when I
grab this oh God he's coming
he'll never find me in this very
convenient hiding spot
good thing he gives up easily
okay so that must have been all the
pictures there couldn't possibly be
anymore
strange not having like a flashlight or
something in a horror game I'm fine with
it and I don't think you need it this is
strange because Amanda look in all the
dark corners and went up let me go in
here because I don't think I've
explored this before
I might
[Music]
you might
yeah if you weren't so predictable you
know come it might actually be a bit of
a fair game
but as it stands
you kind of going easy on me oh this
isn't this isn't any better
oh exit maybe it is better
but where did that other way go
there was another path hey wait a minute
it's that thing again
son of a [ __ ] stole my card I have no
idea why that happened either that
didn't make any sense because there was
like a tape recorder in there
but it closed immediately I think I'm
supposed to go down here
oh I would love to have my other thing
but whatever I'll take two of these
sure
search
Sparks good
surely that won't break open
okay easy
simple even
too simple
hey I found your dumb pictures jerk
there you go there you go they're really
terrible
they're actually
whoa whoa wait what
don't go get your pictures go get your
pictures nobody wants to see my picture
I worked so hard on them for so long and
they're all my own original work you
don't mind if I read this while you're
attacking me I'll have to make people
look at them still see how talented I am
I do if someone looks at him takes all
my precious ideas no they can't do that
they're my characters do not steal well
yeah stealing's bad I guess but hey hey
hey hey hey stop stop it let me stop it
stop it
stop
stop
that's right
now you go think about what you did why
you gotta be so weird man I'm gonna
banish you
Into The Ether
slurp is what you get
that is what you get
now you were a part of me and all of
your amazing ideas are now Mine by law
oh
hello
I'm not ready I guess I didn't need to
do that anyway because there's nothing
here to get
huh I guess I got to just run for it
well whatever
no time for regrets where am I now am I
back where I was or is this a new area
yeah I just won't grab that there we go
okay but either way I'm Gonna Leave This
for the next episode this is a good
stopping point we escape the ink demon
and he'll never haunt us ever again
thank you everyone so much for watching
look forward to more of this very soon
and as always I will see you in the next
video
bye-bye